à la gare de petit manoir au lamentin
les grévistes ont laissé place un chassé
croisé de bus après 57 jours de grève le
trafic reprend enfin et les usagers
retrouve le sourire
c'est super ça c'est très bien parce
qu'on était dans la souffrance des bus
ça fait plaisir ça cheuvreux
le manchot envier alors j'espère que sa
radio et enfin peut-être peut-être eu un
solage le quotidien deux fois on disait
que ça allait démarrer et c'était pas
démarré dans les quartiers des communes
de saint joseph et du lamentin par
exemple les usagers patientent aux
arrêts de bus comme jocelyne en attente
depuis quarante minutes chaque chaton à
vue je serais vraiment content oui parce
que la wii avec la bûche je vais partout
j'ai même quand je vais partout mais ça
va plus je suis à nouveau que
franchement c'est une reprise attendue
1 je serai bien contente
sam salam à roger ah oui entre passion
c'est doute certains tranche et n'hésite
pas à jouer la carte de la sécurité
la patron à tous parce que je vais
produire parce que c'est jamais je vais
pas trop confiance à chaque fois qu'ils
disent qu'il ya un bus sont toujours
obligés de rentrer chez moi à pied mais
avec un peu de patience
et jocelyne est aussi présente après les
57 jours de grève les chauffeurs sur le
trajet le constate les habitudes des
usagers n'ont pas changé malgré la
reprise du trafic annoncée du stop ou
bien comme on entend la famille les
voisins donc il essaie de se débrouiller
comme ils peuvent quoi malgré la reprise
donc c'est une question de se rassurer
parce que des fois on dit que ça reprend
donc après après on peut voir que ça
s'arrête donc c'est une façon de prendre
leurs précautions quoi le trafic sur le
territoire de la cacem a repris
progressivement ce matin les usagers
espèrent que cela dure